from our vantage point hidden high in
the sand dunes above a beach near Cali
we watched as torchlight penetrated the
darkness boorda force and police
officers surrounding a cluster of huts
after a tip-off somewhat had their locks
prized open that usually means one thing
Smuggler's preparing to launch a sea
crossing they're known to use the huts
to hide boats motors and even migrants
just ahead of any attempt no one will be
going anywhere tonight
the team soon find us and we subjected
to an hour of scrutiny this operation
part of an increased effort to stop
migrant crossings partly funded by the
UK cause you see a people who cotton
telephone aeropolis submit a new doozer
por que la policia hallelujah commit
non-kill come in new to yell a police
London Array who would happily serve on
Turkey Italian tutitu to touch it
everyone LED copter cylinders 1000 para
el amigo he say to the party of the
flesh
avvocato the night operation took place
hours of the france's deputy interior
minister visited the beaches around
Calais to see the equipment and teams
being used to control the traffic in
people after a steep rise in attempted
channel crossings in recent weeks
Lauren Nunez met with UK officials
behind the closed doors of a migrant
detention center to discuss their joint
strategy to tackle a lucrative illegal
trade ahead of the visit dozens had been
rounded up from the camp known as the
new jungle where migrants wait for their
chance to cross for many it's now become
too expensive the smuggler is charging
around 3,000 pounds per person for a
seat on a boat no polish on that you
know no consistent sita la virge are
securely seated by Durga
but we met Afghans and Iranian hsihu
told us they had paid the money and was
simply waiting for the green light the
challenge for the smugglers getting
boats and motors to meet demands
and it seems they'll stop at nothing but
small lifeguard lucy gamba tells us
they've used the quiet of the lockdown
period to target the Coast Guard Station
three times in the last six weeks she
shows us a picture of one of their
inflatables found in Dover in all five
was stolen along with other equipment
from the very people who go to the aid
of migrants in distress in the channel
we see Jim Italian default master
exhibit focusing on didi but two keys to
an adaptive axial Amash see before that
in the percents Elizabeth Catherine I
don't you simulations from here England
appears tantalizingly close and it's
easy to understand why so many are
prepared to make the journey and hand
over the cash which drives the smugglers
to keep on operating with summer coming
the challenge for the French and UK
authorities is only set to increase
Michelle Trafford Sky News Calais